he's Jeff Goodman ESPN college
basketball reporter basketball insider I
wanted to have Jeff on because Marvin
Bagley the third just changed college
basketball yesterday
he announced he's going to Duke they
went there the prohibitive favorite to
win the national title already had a
great recruiting class and I wanted to
have Jeff join me because there's a
little bit of a loophole here that
Marvin Bagley the third jumped through
help me with this Jeff on what Bagley
pulled off and is this going to be a
growing trend
well Bagley was supposed to be the
number one player in high school this
season and he goes to high school in
Arizona and this has been in the works
for a while now of him reclassifying and
yesterday he announced not only will he
play college ball this year but he will
play college ball at Duke this season
and every indication is the n-c-double-a
will clear him due starts first day
classes are the 28th
he should be on campus next week he's
still got to go through the process but
he's been taking three online classes
and basically reclassified so he'll be
in this year's class in like you said he
will change college basketball from a
standpoint that the rich get richer
would Duke who already had a terrific
incoming freshman class but also for
college basketball sake this is a kid
that is probably as talented as anybody
who's coming to high school students
probably Anthony Davis in 2011 okay but
he's skipping his senior year
well skipping you know he's older he
would have been an older junior or
senior this year in high school instead
now he's kind of fast-tracked himself
back into his original class per se a
lot of guys do this now they're held
back for athletic purposes I don't know
if that was Bagley's case when his dad
decided to do it but his dad has been
very meticulous in terms of the process
he's kind of the anti Lavar ball in a
sense that he's got a plan he didn't
want his kid to get a lot of attention
so it's not like his son like Alonzo
you know as a huge following a lot of
people don't know about Marvin Bagley
but this is a tremendous talent 610
forward who can do just about everything
but it's going to be interesting to see
how he fits in it Duke & Duke is a
prohibitive favorite now to win it all
but then they were the favorite last
year and weren't that good partially
because of injuries partially because of
chemistry lack of a point guard they've
got a kid named Trayvon Duvall who's a
freshman point guard this year a top 10
player but we'll see if he's as good as
advertised is not a pure point so we'll
see if the runs through the table here
and dominates you said that Bagley the
third would have been the number one
high school player what about Zion
Williamson
now Bagley is clearly better than John
Williamson to me in my opinion and
Marvin Bagley you can make a case that
he might have gone number one and this
is me in my opinion would and went
number one and this past year has
dropped over marquel Falls there there's
a case to be made he would have been in
equation now the interesting thing is
that none of the NBA guys have seen
Marvin Douglas land Persia
none of them so we're all putting him at
number one and I've seen him play 25
times because of his talent but it's
going to be interesting to see all the
NBA guys that are dukes games he's got
the slight edge over kid named Michael
Porter juniors a freshman at Missouri
who was also ultra talented I think both
are franchise changing type NBA players
but I'm watching Bagley in the drew
league and he's got Chris Paul and James
Harden has teammates here I mean he I've
seen enough I don't need to see the high
school video because yeah you can make
high school video look whatever however
you want to look but to see him in the
drew league which is the LA Summer
League with all these pros coming back
that's pretty impressive stuff so he can
play there like he's got a little bit of
Chris Bosh through his game in terms of
the ability to step out make some shots
he can really score he's versatile but
he plays so damn hard as a big and you
just don't see that very often you know
I'm not going to say he's cagey it turns
out how hard he plays
but as a high school player to see it
it's like it's shocking because you just
don't we don't witness not all that
often anymore
a lot of big they play because they're
big right I mean that's always the case
with a lot of the big guys that get to
the NBA do they love the King
this kid plays like he loves the game
and he can do so much but it's going to
be interesting because Dukes got two
bigs a kid named Wendell Carter who's
highly touted coming in who's more of a
true four five and Mark Reese Bolden who
came back to Duke so now I think you're
going to see Bagley play a little bit at
the three and chemistry again because
they've got a lot of big guys is going
to be a concern going into you I'll
leave you with this very quickly I know
you're short on time but do you see this
is any kind of trend where other players
are going to try to get that one year in
college and get to the NBA sooner and do
the same thing Bagley did in high school
yeah I do I might think if if you can do
it and you're ready why wouldn't you do
it it just allows you now again Bagley's
got an NBA ready body did you know so
he's able to do it now there aren't many
guys that are going to be able to fast
track themselves and go a year ahead
physically and emotionally be able to
handle it
I think this kid's going to be fine
Thank You Jeff we appreciate your time
you got a death that's on Jeff Goodman
basketball insider for the mothership
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience